immediate comparisons with with call of
duty as a as a franchise I honestly
think it plays better obviously the
story the story plays out better it
actually has a message to tell that
isn't isn't just sort of you know gross
you know in the it does sort of Barrel
in on a very very tight little
psychological profile of a single
individual and how they fit within the
the broader system that they exist
inside of and how that system has shaped
them and how they have reacted to it so
you know those elements definitely
better the things that were really
interesting playing through this time is
seeing the moments like the the things
that are at this point Call of Duty
touchstones the the aerial assault like
is subverting that mission so much and
for those who don't know what I'm
talking about there's a mission in in
call of duty modern warfare where you
have control of that of a gunship and
basically it'll sound like the the
objective is that you've got a bunch of
people on the ground who you need to who
you need to more or less escort from one
section to another but they're
functionally invincible by game
mechanics and so really all you're doing
is you are uninvent scible super power
raining death from the sky on on an
endless endless stream of Arabs and
Russians and chechnyans
the so that that mission was was kind of
a big deal
it was one of the like things about
Modern Warfare that everyone sort of
talked about and like oh yeah you know
like they they throw in all of these
different kind of missions and they mix
it up and that one was one that they
that people often highlighted and it's
one of the game itself highlights
because when you get to the ending
credits like that's the mission that it
plays over the over the final over the
ending credits and so this does a like
straight callback to that with the you
know similar similar setup similar
scenario where it's like okay you're
just this eye in the sky raining death
from above and then they subvert it by
it's like oh well it mystery you you are
killing civilians because how can you
how can you possibly expect to just like
rain death down on a down on the city
and only hit people you mean to because
oh and I guess this is an important
thing to note in the the call of duty
mission is that that's kind of a whole
part of it is that there you can just
shoot everything with zero consequence
you know if you blow up civilian
buildings they just kind of yell at you
like you can you can demolish a church
and they're you're sure they're done
that you can shoot you know buildings in
fact the the the civilian buildings like
you know if you do shoot them it just
like eventually there's even parts where
it's like actually we've decided we have
determined that those are all like just
empty and full of full of engaged will
host I'll just fire will can you like
blow them all up and they fall down it's
like good shot oh man look at all of
that stuff falling over it's blowing up
real good like they they you know you
get this feedback from the game system
it's like oh you're doing like yeah what
you're doing is awesome this is exciting
this is this is something that you
should want to do more of it's giving
you it's giving you positive feedback
for those actions
you know and and doesn't doesn't pay any
regard to to collateral damage or
civilians and by and large this is a
running running criticism of of Call of
Duty is that civilians are are
perpetually absent but they are around
in in this really weird way it's like
they'll be there occasionally whenever
it wants to like you know just sort of
randomly throw civilians into the mix
but in times where there should be
civilians there aren't and and yeah so
it was it was a really ridiculous moment
and it was an incredibly gross moment in
the Call of Duty game and so here they
subvert it really hard with the with the
which one they said with the white
phosphorus and sorry I was only saw a
bit of the game for the comparison I
would drop it just by the ending is a
really racist ghost tortured in Amazon
pit for a year bit yeah that's a yes
ghost is the one that has the tortured
in the Amazon pit for a year two years
or whatever yeah and then so a lot of
those sort of callbacks in this one to
sort of classic moments in Call of Duty
and especially like in the way that they
handle like I think there's there's
notes that should be taken and how they
handle sort of the consequences of
friendly fire and the consequences of
civilian casualties because modern
warfare certainly does try like modern
warfare one and to make me make
pretenses about caring about civilian
casualties and civilian crossfire you
know with the with the edgy scenes that
that they throw in there in modern
warfare one of course being the the new
king of the city and modern warfare to
the
massacre in the in the airport but if
you notice the way that they're handled
in both time so in modern warfare one
end in to actually both moments are used
to exemplify like they're used to just
show off as a blank they're kicked the
dog moments it's like oh look how crazy
and scary our opponents are they're
willing to go to these extremes and and
the the chain of agency in the chain of
culpability in that are never called
into question whereas you know this is
entirely about that chain of culpability
the chain of you know the chain of
decisions that are made lead to moments
that lead to these decisions the entire
the entire structure that allows them to
happen
and yes the Vietnam in blopps to was a
whitewashing of America that that's
basically I mean that right there
actually describes a lot of calm duty is
that it's whitewashing American
atrocities in various various
engagements I mean there's there isn't a
single historical engagement that they
call of duty has touched on it was not
in some way or another a post hoc
justification of American involvement no
no Russian no Russian has absolutely
nothing on this game in terms of what
it's trying to say in terms of what it's
trying to do because the thing is is
that the no Russian really isn't trying
to say anything you know no Russian is
is there to be edgy and to make you like
it's like you know it's it's a it's a
prank basically it's a joke that's being
played on the player yeah it doesn't
tell you anything and in fact if you
back off and you start looking at no
Russian in the greater context of like
the story itself it makes a zero
sentence like okay how is this supposed
to start a war like basically it's it's
hand waved away with like thing after
thing after thing where it's like oh
somehow
this event by blaming Americans you know
started started World War three like it
was the reason why Russia was was
willing to like launched a massive
simultaneous land war on like the entire
east coast of the United States and so
actually no no sorry
a simultaneous war on Europe and America
comes like well how how and why and it's
like oh well they were already ready to
like you know they were already on a
hair-trigger and it's like well how and
why were they on a hair-trigger said
well because their leaders were you know
kind of scary and and foreign and it's
like no that doesn't that doesn't play
out that doesn't work you know things
happen because of the decisions made by
individuals but in call of duty the
decision-making individuals are always
distant and you know if they're on your
side they're like automatically good
unless they have to be evil for a twist
and if they're on the other side then
they're like automatically evil you know
and this is one of the reasons why black
ops 2 sort of gets it gets a little bit
of my grudging respect is because their
villain was actually you know he was the
closest thing they came to actually
fleshing out their villain in terms of
political motivation oh man world at war
even even yeah the Americans a specific
we're tired been trying to fight their
way home of the Russians we're
xenophobic Patriots who were super crazy
and didn't care about committing war
crimes but it was okay because Nazis
that was fun yeah world at war actually
the American campaign in world at war
really really pissed me off
if for I mean I don't need other reasons
but certainly a big part of it is that
it starts off with like oh man these
Japanese are sure killable let's go kill
a bunch of them it's like that's that's
how the game starts is like watching a
Japanese officer like stab your buddy
and there's like oh there we go and we
got a reason to kill all of them and
yeah it does have you know world at war
has Rezanov so I hate world at war I
really really hate that game it made me
so angry and Rezanov is not enough to
like he's he's probably my like favorite
single thing I would have called duty
even if he is a stock character straight
from central casting but like my god I
hate world at war so much in in big part
because world at war like even the vet
it like even the best moments in that
terrible terrible game they are all just
like lifted straight from other better
movies oh I shouldn't say other movies
they're all just lifted straight from
from movies and particularly movies that
are better than in the and if I remember
correctly like Modern Warfare at least
toned down the wall-to-wall gunfire
sound design from from the first three
Call of Duty's and it was particularly
grating after college 82 like it toned
it down a bit it was still it still gave
me a headache and the world at war just
made it like a million times worse
I don't think the sound design has been
worse in the series than it was in in
world at war in terms of like just
grading grading gunfire wall to wall for
hours on end and of course all of the
college eating games actually not quite
all of them but almost all of them like
they they end emission it's like okay
the mission is over it's like yeah
overall the stuff can't fly now you all
gum wank here somebody you know then we
move over here and ORS hell but we don't
really don't care because it gave us a
chance to kill a bunch more Japanese
we're gonna go get them and it was like
oh we're gonna get revenge we're gonna
get so much revenge I mean yeah the
terrified that their audience would like
lose interest if they'd stop shouting at
them for more than 30 seconds I would I
would actually enjoy they should do a
call of duty from Menendez's perspective
because that would actually be
interesting and yeah the so stuff like
Call of Duty is junk food media so long
as you don't think about it you can
consume it happily and forget about it
if you think about it though it's super
gross and even for like I I consume a
lot of junk food media I like junk food
media ultimately like it's taken me
years to sort of come to the it come to
the conclusion to accept it it's like
that I like junk food media the problem
with Call of Duty is that even buy junk
food media's standards it's it's gross
like it's it's super gross and most like
a lot of junk food media is full of like
really kind of just bad and questionable
themes and messages Call of Duty's is is
especially egregious because by and
large what it's doing is it's it's
confirming a narrative of militarism and
the inevitability of conflict that
basically justifies not not just like
you've got bad messages that justify
things like say restrictive gender roles
and yeah that's bad but Call of Duty has
messages that justify war you know they
justify like the the exclusion and
murder of
other people that it's like hey there's
the scary brown people and they're going
to eventually get around to like doing
bad things to you so we should probably
just take care of that quick and early
before they have a chance you know it it
promotes the value of preemptive strike
it promotes the value of military
buildup it promotes the value of
conflict as a sorry of militarism as a
conflict resolution method of like above
and you know before anything else like
the diplomacy is routinely like where
it's even remotely attempted diplomacy
is routinely depicted as you know the
the soft pathetic engineering of stupid
baby men who who don't know what they're
doing and are and are just wasting time
because like clearly the people on the
other side of the table they're just
planning on shooting you the moment you
like walk out of this room do you
acknowledge that the cheeseburger you're
eating is junk food that mean it's not
bad for you anymore
no not necessarily like the cheeseburger
is probably still bad for you and you
know a lot of junk food media is it's
kind of bad for you but at the same time
with media more so than the cheeseburger
it's you know being being critical and
being aware of the media that you're
consuming it doesn't inoculate you but
it definitely changes the way that
you're that you're interacting with it
in in ways that can can do a lot to sort
of mitigate the damage because the thing
is that the the damages that comes out
of media is by and large in how that
media reinforces the things that you
already believe so you know it takes
especially sort of you know potent and
persistent media to completely change
someone's opinions on a subject matter
so yeah I mean and that's kind of the
whole thing like with the the circle of
talking about like okay well you know
violence and videogames or aggression
and video games and how that impacts
people and you know there's a lot of
people will sort of dismiss it as like
oh well you know the only people that it
does that to or ones who are already
already aggressive people and say well
you know to to a degree that's true but
that's kind of half the problem is that
you know hyper aggressive media or media
that confirms hyperaggression as a good
thing is going to take people who are
already aggressive and just make them
more aggressive you know and how do you
know that you're not a person who's
inclined to aggression like you've got a
stereotype in your head of what an
aggressive person looks like but that
doesn't mean that you are not an
aggressive person so you know it is more
complicated and of course if you consume
enough of it well it's going to make if
it makes you know a non aggressive
person a little more aggressive well
we're talking over time so now all of a
sudden you're a little more aggressive
person and that means you're now you
know and if you keep going you're gonna
get I mean it's complicated and it plays
out over over long spans of time and
that's you know that's sort of the whole
thing and I know people were chatting
about the Bechdel test earlier you know
how like things do need to be looked at
you know as trends over time because you
know we're not just it's not know one
thing like it is incredibly rare for a
singular event or a singular piece of
media to completely alter the way that
someone looks at things if they don't
already have you know especially if they
don't already have an inclination
towards it often people who say they're
just like oh this thing like completely
changed the way that I look at the world
usually it's because that thing answered
or like filled in gaps or answered
questions that they were already asking
epiphanies are seen and this is sort of
what I was mentioning earlier is that so
epiphanies are are an example of
immediate impact but epiphanies are rare
and usually an epiphany comes in
relation to something that you're
already kind of looking for or expecting
so it's like oh I'm looking
for you know what am I going to do with
my life and then something comes along
that likes you know it hits the right
switches here like that's what I should
do with my life epiphany moment it is
incredibly rare for someone to be you
know for something to come along and
give someone at any moment that they
weren't looking for you know it's like I
was happy in my life and then something
happened and I just kind of like changed
everything you know unless it's a
suitably extreme kind of Epiphany moment
where it's like I was you know I was
just kind of happily sailing through my
life and then I got a cancer diagnosis
and it's like okay that's going you know
it usually needs to be something like
suitably extreme to suitably all to you
know to extremely alter someone's
disposition or outlook
all right that's still going that's got
a couple minutes left
yeah the ethics of porn are complicated
I did a couple classes on that back in
back in University and it's it's
complicated is complicated is is a
simple way of putting it because you're
dealing with not only sort of the the
subject matter itself but you're also
dealing with an industry you know that
there is a production industry behind it
and how that production industry
interacts with the audience and how that
you know then interacts with the subject
matter and you know the performers and
so on and so forth
it's it's complicated and messy and so
you know yeah on one hand you know you
are talking about the agency of the
agency of the performers but a lot of
times like the agency the performers is
already kind of you know in question and
a lot of that has changed like the
internet has has changed that in a lot
of ways because it's harder for you know
production companies to kind of
monopolize the monopolize the space and
you know performers are able to kind of
strike out on their own and and just
support themselves through you know well
I can't use patreon because patron
doesn't it doesn't let them but you know
various services where they can you know
basically be independent owner operators
and and do their thing that way
plus you know just make it at home video
cameras are video cameras are cheap and
and one of the things that people sorry
well I was coming down coming back one
of the things about you know sort of who
were mentioning misogyny just as a
general like concept a thing
and and what it is you know that it's
not just like you know it's not just
like oh man I hate all women and I want
to slap them around so well of course
not
you know it comes up in more subtle more
subtle things and particularly in a
sense of you know disposability your
vile ability fungibility you know that
the one woman you know one woman is
replaceable with another and you know or
just that you know vile ability is that
it's like okay well there's certain
things that are simply just acceptable
to do in that space and to use a
real-world example from something that
happened to an associate of mine like
you know someone thought it was
appropriate to you know take candid
photos of them from from a convention
and then like write creepy messages all
over it and you know and and this act
you know was then certain justifies like
oh well it's for its for this
metafiction sort of thing that I'm
working on it's like that space like you
don't know that person you're not
involved in their life you're not their
friend you're not their associate you
haven't talked to them at all about this
in fact you know when you have contacted
them it seems like they don't want to
have anything to do with you and but
just that sense that it's like no this
is an okay thing to do in this space to
to someone that it's like they should be
okay with this you know that level of
sort of willful imposition on another
person you know that's a sense of vile
ability that it's like no I I can I can
do this this is an okay thing to do you
know yeah